[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
لاول مره البحريه الروسيه تتعرض لهجوم
اوكرانيا في الفوسفور ومنفذوه هجوم بيل
جوردن
على وقع اصوات اشتباكات متقطعه في الخرطوم
واشنطن تعلن سعيها لايجاد اليه لمراقبه
الهدنه
قيادي بارز في حزب عمران خان يستقيلوا من
منصبه والحكومه الباكستانيه تبحث خطه لحظر
الحزب
ره
الى قرب التوصل لحل ازمه الدين مع بايدن
ويؤكد وجود خلافات بشان الانفاق
[موسيقى]
هجوم هو الاول من نوعه منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا اذ اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
التصدي لهجوم بحري شنته ثلاثه زوارق
اوكرانيه سريعه مسيره على سفينه ايفانخورس
التابعه لاصول البحر الاسود في منطقه مضيق
البوسفور مؤكدا انه تم تدمير جميع القوارب
المهاجمه الهجوم تزامن مع اول ظهور على
نيل المجموعه المسلحه التي اعلنت تبنيها
للهجوم على بلغارد الروسيه
[موسيقى]
توعد وزير الدفاع الروسيه سرقه برد صارم
على اي محاولات للتوغل مسلحين اوكرانيين
للحدود الروسيه مشيرا الى مقتل سبعين
مسلحا في بلغورت هذا ونشرت وسائل الاعلام
روسيه مقاطع مصوره قالت انها لمركبات
امريكيه الصنع استخدمها المسلحون
الاوكرانيون في الهجوم على منطقه الحدوديه
وذكرت التقارير الروسيه بان المواجهات
تسببت في تضرر 500 منزل على الاقل في
بالكود
[موسيقى]
اذا مجموعه فيلق روسيا الحره تخطف المشهد
في الحرب الاوكرانيه بعدما نفذت احدى اكبر
عمليات التوغل المنطلقه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه منذ بدء الحرب نحو روسيا في
هجوم النادر في منطقه بلغارد من هم هؤلاء
الجنود الذين يقفون وراء هذه العمليه فيلق
روسيا الحره ووصفهم الكريم بالارهابيين
ومن اين جاءوا المقاتلون مشاهديناهم اعضاء
في وحده متطوعين روس يقاتلون الى جانب
القوات الاوكرانيه ضد بلادهم وسبب النقمه
هي النقمه على سياسات الكريملان يعود
تشكيل هذه الحركه المنظمه الى مارس 2022
وفق ما كشفته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه التي قالت بان فيلق روسيا الحره
يعمل تحت مظله الفيلق الدولي الاوكراني
وهي قوه قتاليه تضم وحدات مكونه من
متطوعين الامريكيين وبريطانيين وايضا من
جنسيات اخرى بالاضافه الى بيلاروسيين
وجورجين وغيرهم هذه القوات مشاهدينا تشرف
عليها القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ويقودها
ضباط اوكرانيون وفقا طبعا
ولكن اغلب عناصر هذه القوات من دون خبره
عسكريه ومنهم لم يبلغ العشرين عام يقول
التقرير رغم نافيكياف لاكثر من مره الصله
المباشره بهذه المجموعه تختلف اسباب تطوع
هؤلاء الشباب في صفوف الجيش الاوكراني ضد
جيش بلادهم ما بين النقلاتهم على الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ومعارضتهم لقرار
الهجوم الروسي وانهم كانوا يسكنون بالاساس
في اوكرانيا عند بدايه الحرب وهم الان
يدافعون عن هذه البلاد التي تبنتهم
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من موسكو عبر سكايب
اندريه
المحلل السياسي استاذ ابدا من الهجوم على
البوسفور هو اول هجوم من نوعه طبعا شاهدنا
الهجوم البري بالامن الاخيره نحن نتحدث عن
تطورات يعني مختلفه
بمصار الحرب وعن تغيير بالتكتيكات للهجوم
على روسيا ماذا يعني ذلك
تغيير مرتبط فقط انا اقصد هذا الهجوم على
بودره على الاراده الروسيه مرتبط فقط
بالهدف السياسي بالنسبه لسلطات الاوكرانيه
هو طبعا لكي يكون
الاهتمام متزايد لهذا الهجوم وسحب جزر
كبير من الاحتمام عن سقوط ضخم ضخمه مدينه
بخمه الى الاراضي قوات فبتعمل الحل هناك
عزل الهجوم له الاهداف وبعد السياسيه
والاعلاميه قبل كل شيء وليس عسكريه
بسبب ان هذه الهجوم لم يؤدي الى الاضرار
الكبيره الى اضرار بالنسبه للبنيه التحتيه
العسكريه الروسيه والى ما هنالك نحن نتحدث
عن الهجوم في البلدات الصغيره فلا توجد
هناك
المراكز الاستراتيجيه ولا شيء ولاهداف
العسكريه وغيرها ومن جيده تقول الهدف
الاعلامي قبل كل شيء لاجل سحب الاهتمام
الكبير من سقوط ضخمه لذلك
ظهور هذه المجموعه المسلحه والتي هي طبعا
هي مجموعه من مجموعتين تعتبر مجموعات
مسلحه الى جانب تقاتل اللجانب الجيش
الاوكراني منذ بدايه الحرب منذ بدايه
الحرب كان هناك الكثير من الغموض يعني يلف
الاعلام وكل التفاصيل حول هذه المجموعه
وكان هناك صعوبه لنا حتى كاعلام ان نجد
يعني تفاصيل عن هذه المجموعه اليوم خروجها
الى العلن مع طبعا رفض غربي امريكي من
تغطيه عمليات اوكرانيا بالداخل الروسي هل
هي للاعب على وترين اولا عمليه يعني
استخدام بالعمليات داخل روسيا وثانيا
اللعب على وتر الانقسامات الداخليه
الروسيه
وهو رفض الامريكي لاستخدام الاسلحه
الغربيه في الاراده الروسيه المعترفه بهذا
الشكل الدوليا فنحن نتحدث عن محافظ
هناك توافق بانه هي المحافظه الروسيه
فلذلك هذا ما يسمى بالمجموعه فيلق روسيا
الحره ما اسمه هو فقط مشروع اعلامي ليس
اكثر لماذا لان طبعا السلطات الاوكرانيه
تم في اي اتصال اي تواصل مع هذه المجموعه
ولكن واضح تماما ان هذه المجموعه قد حصلت
على المدرعات والتقنيات الثقيله
الاوكرانيه ولكن في نفس الوقت نفي
الاوكراني فترون هذا النفي الاوكراني
لا تريد ان تطورت في هذا الهجوم
وبالاساس هذا الهجوم على محافظه
على الاراده الروسيه فطبعا السلطات
الاوكرانيه لا تريد ان تكون هناك علاقه
مباشره بين هذا الهجوم وما بين هذه
السلطات ولكن نحن ندرك تماما انا ذكرت
سابقا هذه المشروع اعلامي هذه مجموعه ما
يسمى بروسيا الحره
يعني هو المشروع الاعلامي لا توجد هناك بس
واضحا واضح هذه النقطه المهمه بالنسبه
للمشاهدين العرب يعني لا يوجد هناك فرق
بين بين روسي واوكرانيين
لو سمحت يعني ساسرد هذا الخبر معكم ومع
المشاهدين واعود اليك مشاهدينا حذر قائد
مجموعه فاقنر الروسيه من ان روسيا قد
تواجه ثوره مماثله لثوره 1917 وتخسر الحرب
في اوكرانيا ما لم تتعامل النخبه بجديه مع
الحرب واكد بان الحرب في اوكرانيا بان
اوكرانيا تعد لهجوم مضاد يهدف الى دحر
القوات الروسيه الى حدود ما قبل 2014
عندما ضمت روسيا شبه جزيره القرم واضاف
بان اوكرانيا ستحاول محاصره مخمود وشن
هجوم في القرن ولن يكون هذا السيناريو في
صالح روسيا لذا يجب الاستعداد لحرب شاقه
كما كشف قائد فاجنر عن مقتل نحو 10 الاف
سجين تم تجنيدهم للقتال مع قواته في
اوكرانيا
على مدار العمليات جنته خمسين الف سجين
قتل منهم حوالي 20% وقتل العدد ذاته من
المتعاقدين معنا بالاضافه الى نحو 20% من
الجرحى والذين اصيبوا ولا يستطيعون القيام
بالمهام القتاليه خلال الاشهر المقبله تم
القضاء على ما يقارب من 50 الى 70 الف
مقاتل من القوات الاوكرانيه ولديهم اصابات
بما يعادل 300 الف وذلك لان اجلاءهم كان
صعبا
اعود اليك سيد
المحلل السياسي من موسكو ما سمعناه عن
بريجوشين خصوصا وان يعني بالفتره الماضيه
كان هناك الكثير من
التحديث ومن التحليلات بان بوتين يستخدمه
لاحكام السيطره داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
ولكبح جماح الجنرالات هناك هل اليوم
يستخدم ايضا ضد النخبه بظل يعني معرفه
الداخل بان هؤلاء اصبحوا يمتعدون مما يحصل
وخصوصا ان التحديد بثوره يعني هي على حساب
هذه النخبه التي جنت كل ثروتها بالماضي
بصراحه لا اعتقد بان يوجد هناك عامل داخلي
بسبب ان
شاهدناه من قبل هذه تصريحات المنتقده تجاه
حتى القياده الروسيه بما في ذلك الخيار
العسكريه
الروسيه براي شخصي مرتبط قبل كل شيء
بمحاوله التضليل الطرف الاوكراني وامريكي
لتقول كان في روسيا توجد هناك الخلافات
الداخليه كان نحن على حافه الازمه
السياسيه الداخليه ولكن كل ذلك لاجل تضليل
ان نذاكر
تحصل على المعلومات عفوا
التقنيات على الزخائر على الاسلحه على
مدرعات حتى من قبل
وزاره الدفاع من مستودعات تابعه لوزاره
الدفاع لذلك يعني انا اعتقد طبعا نحن نسمع
هذه التصريحات طبعا من جهه مقلقه من جيل
اخرى عن اعتقد يجب ان ننظر على الواقع
والواقع يقول بان قوه
من تحرير ضخمه
تماكنت من تحرير الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الاخرى فلذلك يعني انا اعتقد ان هناك لعبه
الاعلاميه قبل كل شيء سياسيه ولكن على
الارض الاوضاع مختلفه تماما شكرا لك استاذ
المحلل السياسي حدثنا من موسكو
عرف بعراب معاهده ستارت النوويه واليوم
يهدد بنسفها ويتحدث عن نهايه نوويه للعالم
نتحدث هنا مشاهدينا عن نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي ديمتري صاحب التهديدات
النوويه الذي يتسلح كل مره بالعقيده
الروسيه التي تقول بان دستوره بلاده شرع
استخدام النووي للدفاع عن الدوله والاراضي
الروسيه طبعا وعند اي تحرك غربي تجاه
اوكرانيا سواء كان لدعمها عسكريا او ماديا
وحتى معنويا تتصدر من جديد تهديدات
النوويه ليؤكد بان استخدام النووي ليس
خدعه شغل سابقا منصب رئيس روسيا الثالث من
عام 2008 الى عام 2012 ليشغل فيما بعد
رئيس وزراء روسيا العاشر وخلال فتره حكمه
نجح هذا الرجل بتوقيع ما هو معروف بمعاهده
ستارت لتخفي الاسلحه النوويه بين كل من
روسيا والولايات المتحده هذا الامر طبعا
طرح تساؤلات من قبل المراقبين حول تطرف
اراء تجاهها تصعيده ودعمه الدائم لبلاده
لاستخدام النووي منذ بدء الحرب على
اوكرانيا
بان تهديداته النوويه لا ينشرها فقط على
تطبيق تيليجرام بل ايضا ينشرها على منصه
تويتر الغربيه كما نشاهد هنا باللغه
الروسيه مما دفع المراقبين الى التساؤل
لماذا لا يتم حظر حساب حتى هذا اليوم بسبب
دعوته لحرب نوويه بل وان حسابه كما نشاهد
هو موثق بالعلامه الزرقاء او العلامه
الرماديه في اشاره على حساب حكومي او رسمي
[موسيقى]
صرح البيت الابيض لقناه العربيه عن الهدنه
في السودان وقال انها متماسكه بشكل عام
لكن الوقت مبكر للحكم عليها الهدف من
الهدنه حسب البيت الابيض هو السماح بوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه للمداريين كما اضاف
بان الولايات المتحده ستنظر في خطوات اخرى
في المرحله القادمه وعلى انها تعمل مع
شركائها في اليه لمراقبه الهدنه في
السودان
بدورها اشادت الخارجيه الفرنسيه بجهود
السعوديه والامريكيه لارساء الهدنه في
السودان ودعت الى ضروره الالتزام من قبل
الطرفي اي طرفي النزاع بالهدنه لاستقرار
المنطقه هناك للمتابعه
بالجهود المبذوله من كره الاطراف التي
ساهمت
الولايات المتحده السعوديه
لتاسيس يعني قاعده هنا مع الاسف ما
شاهدناه وبالعكس خرق الوقف الاطلاق النار
مستمر فندعوا الطرفين الى وقف اطلاق النار
مستدام والى الرجوع الى المفاوضات بمشاركه
المجتمع المدني السوداني ايضا
شهر ونصف على بدء الاقتتال الداخلي في
السودان ولا جديد حتى الان ورغم الهدن
المؤقته لوقف النار لا بوادر لحل نهائي
تلوح في الافق الخاسر الاول والاكبر في
هذا الصراع العسكري هو المواطن السوداني
الذي بات يعاني الامل اثر حاله الشلل
والنقص الكبير في المواد الاساسيه
والخدمات والمساعدات الانسانيه يغدو
المشهد اكثر تعقيدا يوما بعد يوم مع تشابك
خريطه وانتشار وسيطرات كل من قوات الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع وتحديدا في العاصمه
الخرطوم اذ يحكم مشاهدينا الجيش السوداني
قبضته على جميع المدن ما عدا بعض المناطق
بدرفور والخرطوم اما في الخرطوم طبعا
فيسيطر على الجزء الاكبر من القياده
العامه كما يسيطر على المناطق العسكريه
المعروفه الموزعه في المدن الثلاث في
ولايه الخرطوم بالاضافه الى منطقه وادي
سيدنا العسكريه
حيث المطار العسكري الذي تم استخدامه
لاجلاء الجاليات الاجنبيه وتتحرك منه طبعا
الطائرات الطائرات المسلحه وسلاح الجو
السوداني في المقابل تسيطر قوات الدعم
السريع على القصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم
وعدد من الوزارات بالاضافه لانتشارها في
منطقه بحري وجنوب ايضا الخرطوم وفي
المناطق السكنيه شرق الخرطوم سكان ام
درمان بولايه الخرطوم في السودان ناشد
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بالحفاظ على وقف
اطلاق النار وحقن الدماء كما روى السكان
طبعا البعض من تجاربهم القاسيه اثناء
القتال بين الاطراف السودانيه
كان الوضع سيء جدا جدا كنا بننام على
الاعلانات المدافع والدانات والرصاص في
منازلنا في منازلنا انعدام كل المقاومه
الحياه من الادويه
واغذيه وغير وغيره لا نش
تر وقروش ما في سيوله ما في بنكك واقف
عشان كذا
والله بصراحه
يعني امبارح بسيط
الناس دي مش كانوا عندنا العرس لانه بيقول
لك الكهرباء والمويه
الحمد لله من اليوم الثالث الامور الحمد
لله هذا لكن في حذر شديد يعني
ومع دخول وقفه اطلاق النار بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع يومه الثاني شهدت
شوارع مدينه ام درمان بولايه الخرطوم بعضا
من عوده مظاهر الحياه الطبيعيه فلنتابع
من الخرطوم ما ينضم الينا مشاهدينا
الصحافه عمار ابو شيبه عمار كيف هي
الاوضاع على الارض خارطه يعني الاشتباكات
المساعدات الانسانيه هل هناك التزام فعلا
بالهدن المعلنه لتمرير المساعدات
الانسانيه
نعم يمكن ان نقول بشكل واضح انه ليس هنالك
التزام بالهدن بالهدن خاصه في يومها
الثاني وهذا من خلال عده اشتباكات عسكريه
جرت منذ صباح الباكر وحتى قبل الدخول لهذا
المباشر خاصه هنا في الشرق العاصمه
الخرطوم وجنوب العاصمه الخرطوم وحتى في
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم عدد اليها الاشتباكات
من جديد مدينه بحري كان لها هذا النصيب من
هذه الاشتباكات خاصه في شمال المدينه في
منطقه القدر وعدد من المناطق المتاخمه
لهذه المنطقه مدينه ام درمان شهدت ايضا
كذلك عدد من الاشتباكات العسكريه داخل
الاحياء وايضا كذلك في سلاح المهندسين وفي
غربيه المدينه وبحسب شهود العيان تم تداول
فيديو لسقوط طائره عسكريه تتبع للجيش
السوداني وايضا عدد من المناطق الاخرى
دارت فيها اشتباكات عنيفه بحسب شهود عيان
وبحسب معلومات ميدانيه تحصلنا عليها هذه
الخريطه
العسكريه الميدانيه انتشرت بشكل واضح في
عدد من المناطق ما يعني ان الاشتباكات
اثرت بشكل كبير هو بنسبه كبيره على نسبه
الحفاظ على تماسك الهدنه الثالثه عشر وهذه
الهدنه التي تم التمهيد لها بشكل واضح منذ
ان تم توقيعها في جده فعلا جده الاخير
وهذا التوقيع الاخير كان قد حمل عده
مضامين هذه المضامين كان ابرزها
وبحسب البيانات من الطرفين وحتى الفاعلين
في توقيع هذه
الاتفاقيه الاخيره بتسهيل من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت الاشاره الابرز الى انها
هذه الاتفاقيه او هذا الاعلان الجديد
الهدف الاساسي منه هو وقف اطلاق النار من
اجل المساعده الانسانيه طالما تجدد النار
الان وتجددت الاشتباكات يصعب دخول
المساعدات الانسانيه لعدد كبير من المناطق
خاصه في العاصمه الخ التي تعاني منذ اكثر
من شهر في نقص حاد من الادويه وحتى كذلك
الاغذيه في كثير جدا من المناطق التي
تاثرت بشكل واضح من باعتبار ان الطرق لا
يستطيع عدد كبير من التجار الذين لديهم
عدد من البضائع عن يوصلها لتلك المناطق
كما ان المستشفيات يوما بعد يوم تزداد
فيها الحاله الصحيه سوءا وتخرج يوما بعد
يوم ايضا عدد من المرافق الصحيه
والمستشفيات من الخدمه ما يشير ايضا كذلك
بتصريحات المتحده ومنظمه الصحه العالميه
لان الوضع قد اقترب من الانهيار والمقصود
من الوضع الصحي هذه النقاط الكثيره ومع
دخول اليوم الثاني من الهدنه ودخول هذه
الاشتباكات الى مناطق جديده واشتباكات
عنيفه وخفيفه سنبقى نتابع معكم
ومعك نقل
الاصل شكرا لك عمار ابو شاب حدثنا من
الخرطوم
التاسع مستمره واصلها بعد قليل
القضاء اللبنانيه يسحب جوازي سفر حاكم مصر
في لبنان ويمنعه من السفر بعد استجوابه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل التاسعه مشاهدينا
من باكستان حيث استقال القناديل البارز في
حزب عمران خان رئيس وزراء باكستان السابق
فؤاد شودري من حزبه واوضح فؤاد شودري عبر
تغريده على حسابه على تويتر بانه قرر اخذ
استراحه من السياسه والاستقاله من الحزب
ياتي ذلك بعدما واجه حزبه الذي ينفي
القيام باعمال عنف حمله قمع في اعقاب
الاحتجاجات الاخيره
تصعد جديد قد تشهده باكستان والسبب ان
الحكومه تدرس حظر حركه انصاف وهي حزب رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان ووزير الدفاع
الباكستاني عاصف خواجه قال في بيان له ان
الحكومه تدرس فرض حظر على حركه انصاف بعد
احداث التاسع من مايو والتي قام فيها
مناصروخان باضراب النار باضراب النار في
المباني الحكوميه
والمركبات وشن هجمات على الشرطه
والعسكريين والمنشات احتجاجا على اعتقال
رئيس الوزراء السابق
ومحاكمته اما عن التداعيات المحتمله في
حال اصدر قرار حظر الحزب او اصدر هذا
القرار فذلك يعني توترا وتصعيدا كبيرا
يحتمل ان يخرج عن الحزب او انصاره وفقا
لمقربين او يحتمل ان يخرج عن كل من ينتمون
الى الحزب وفقا من مقربين من خان كما ان
حظر يحتاج لتجاوز قوانين ومواد دستوريه
لان حركه انصاف حزب سياسي مسجل ومرخص
ويخوض الانتخابات وفقا لحمايه الدستور
الباكستاني ويستحيل حظر هذا الحزب او اي
حزب الا بحكم من المحكمه العليا او بتعديل
من التعديل الدستوري يقره البرلمان وهذا
ما قد تلجا اليه الحكومه الباكستانيه
الحاليه ويعد مشاهدينا عمران خان هو رئيس
الوزراء الوحيد في تاريخ باكستان الذي تمت
الاطاحه به من خلال التصويت بحجب الثقه
حيث يواجه عدد كبير من القضايا المرفوعه
ضده طبعا من بينها الارهاب وغسيل الاموال
والتامر على الدوله وغيرها من التهم
[موسيقى]
منع القضاء اللبنانيه حاكم المصرف المركزي
رياض سلامه من السفر بعد استجوابه سلامه
كان قد مثل اليوم امام المحامي العام
التمييزي في بيروت وسمرت الجلسه ساعه
وعشرين دقيقه حجز
بنتجاتها وحجز بنتجتها المحامي العام
جوازي سفر حاكم مصر في لبنان الفرنسي
واللبناني وتركه
رهن التحقيق الى ذلك اجتمع القنصل
الالماني صباح اليوم النائب العام
التمييزي القاضي غسان عويدات ووضعه في
صوره مذكره التوقيف الالمانيه الصادره بحق
سلامه وفي الموازات تقدم وكلاء الحاكم
القانونيون في فرنسا بطعن امام القضاء
الفرنسي لاسترداد مذكره التوقيف الفرنسيه
المعممه عبر النشره الحمراء
من لبنان الى جارته سوريا حيث اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن استهداف له صدف مسيره له من
الاراضي السوريه وردد على ذلك قام الجيش
الاسرائيلي باطلاق النار في الاتجاه الذي
انطلقت منه النيران وقال المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي افخاي الدرعي بان
المسيره كانت تقوم بمهمه روتينيه في
المنطقه مشيرا الى ان المسيره انجزت
المهام ولم تسجل اي اضرار
بالعوده مشاهدينا الى الموضوع الباكستاني
ينضم الي من اسلام اباد رؤوف حسن مستشار
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
استاذ رؤوف
بانتظار ان تجهز الصوره طبعا الموضوع
الاساسي اليوم هو حظر حزب الرئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق عمران خان من قبل
السلطات الباكستانيه ساعود اليك استاذ
رؤوف استاذ رؤوف اليوم هل باستطاعه يعني
السلطات الباكستانيه حظر الحزب
على ما يبدو بان هناك
تفضل استاذ رؤوف يمكننا سماعك
ما زالت مشكله الصوت موجوده شكرا لك استاذ
رؤوف حسن مستشار رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق عمران خان كان من المفروض ان نستمع
الى وجهه نظر يعني فريق خان بموضوع حظر
الحزب وطبعا استقاله عدد كبير من الاعضاء
بالعوده الى
سياق التاسعه وتحديدا الى الانتخابات
التركيه فقبل ايام من انتخابات الاعاده
الرئاسيه في تركيا حدث خلاف داخل حزب رئيس
الرئيس السابق اردوغان بشان التمسك بما
يسميه البعض برنامجا اقتصاديا غير مستدام
بحسب وكاله رويترز حيث اجتمعت مجموعه غير
رسميه من اعضاء الحزب الحاكم في الاسابيع
الاخيره لمناقشه كيف يمكن ان تتبنى سياسه
جديده لرفع اسعار الفائده تدريجيا وافادت
مصادر مطلعه لوكاله رويتورز بان اردوغان
ليس مشاركا بشكل مباشر في المحادثات التي
تشمل بعض اعضاء حزب العداله والتنميه
من جهه اخرى هناك مسؤولون واعضاء لمجلس
الوزراء صرحوا علنا بانهم يريدون التمسك
بالبرنامج الحالي لتعزيز الصادرات والنمو
الاقتصاديه
هذا ويواصل الناخبون الاتراك المقيمون في
الخارج الادلاء باصواتهم في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
وقد تجاوز عدد من ادلب اصواتهم المليون
و700 الف حتى يوم امس طبعا في الممثليات
الخارجيه والمعابر الحدوديه ومن المقرر ان
تنتهي عمليه التصويت في الممثليات
الخارجيه اليوم فيما تستمر في المعابر
الحدوديه حتى الثامن والعشرين من مايو
في تركيا ايضا فرض تحالف الاجداد اسمه في
المشهد الانتخابي فما بين دعم سنان اوجان
المرشح الخاسر في الجوله الاولى لاردوغان
ودعم رئيس حزب النصر المعارض لمرشح
المعارضه كمال كلتشدار اوغلو انقسم
التحالف بشكل فعلي وباتت حسابات الاصوات
بين المعسكرين تشغل الشارع التركي
فالمتابع التفاصيل
اتضح المشهد السياسي في تركيا قبل
انتخابات الاعاده لاحد القادم
الاصتفافات اكتملت مع انقسام تحالف
الاجداد بين المرشحين الرئيسيين في
الانتخابات الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وزعيم
المعارضه كمال كلجد
زعيم المعارضه الذي خسر في البرلمان تلقى
دفعه معنويه باعلان حزب النصر المعادي
للاجئين دعمه له
حتى وان لم يكن هذا هدفه الا ان الرئيس
اردوغان سيقدره على صعيد اخر الاتفاق بين
كيلج دار اوغلو واوزداد جاء وفق صفقه
تبادل مصالح تحالف الامه بصوره عامه مبني
على تقاسم المصالح لذلك لن ينجح في جوله
الاعاده
وتركزت الدعايه الانتخابيه
ومعسكره قبل جوله الاعاده على ترحيل
اللاجئين من تركيا في محاوله اخيره لجذب
القوميين المتشددين الذين صوتوا لسنانوغان
في الجوله الاولى
بعد دعم حزب النصر
تتجه الانظار نحو الكتله الكرديه المؤيده
لحز
ب وهي التي دعمت زعيم المعارضه في الجوله
الاولى فازداغ يعادي الحزمه الكردي بقدر
ما يعادي وجود اللاجئين في تركيا وهنا
السؤال يعود مجددا هل ستنحاز هذه الكتله
مره ثانيه
بعد تحالفه مع
العربيه اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
وفي ازمه الدين الامريكي اشار رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن كارثه بعد لقائه
ببايدن الى امكانيه تحقيق تقدم بشان الدين
العام لكنه اتهم الديمقراطيين بالانفاق
الزائد مضيفا انهم لا يملكون خطه لذلك
داعيا الى حل ازمه الانفاق كما دعم كارثي
الى عدم القاء اللوم على الجمهوريين
شعوب السنه انا لست سيناتورا ولا اسيطر
على مجلس الشيوخ لماذا لم يمرروا قرارا
الرئيس لم يحدثنا لسبعه وتسعين يوما فلا
تلقوا باللوم علي للتواصل مع الديمقراطيين
للتوصل الى الرئيس للقاء والاجتماعي به لا
تلومون على هذا القرار الذي قدمناه نضع
الانفاق للحكومه ونزيده واحد في المئه لكل
عام كي نواكب الاقتصاد كانت هذه فكره
ديمقراطيه فليس ذنب اليوم ان الديمقراطيين
اصبحوا متطرفين جدا وبعيدين جدا باتجاه
الجناح الاشتراكي ويعارضون متطلبات العمل
ويعارضون ادخار الدولار
[موسيقى]
المشكله هي ان الديمقراطيين استلموا
السلطه وزادوا الانفاق الى اعلى المستويات
التي شهدناها في اي وقت بتاريخ البلاد
مقارنه بالناتج المحلي الاجمالي والان
لدينا اعلى دين في تاريخ امريكا لذا اعتقد
انه من المنطقي والعقلاني ان ننفق اقل في
العام المقبل على كل منزل اي يفعل ذلك
يتصدران مشهد الحرب البارده بين مرشحي
الحزب الجمهوري او مرشحي لحزب الجمهوري في
السباق الى البيت الابيض المعركه
الانتخابيه بين الرجلين بدات بعدما قرر
ديسانتس اعلان ترشحه رسميا عبر تويتر ولكن
من هو المرشح المفضل للجمهوريين لنيل لقب
سيد البيت الابيض بعدما اكدت مشاهدينا
استطلاعات الراي بان ديسانتس وتراب الاوفر
حظا للفوز بترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
والمرشحون الجمهوريون المعلنون الاخرون
وابرزهم طبعا نكهه التي لا يتجاوزون
الخمسه بالمئه فقط من الاصوات طريقه
ديسنتوس الى البيت الابيض لن تكون سهله
لكنه عمل منذ انتخابيه حاكما لولايه
فلوريد عام 2018 بعدما تلقى الدعم اي دعم
ترامب الذي كان رئيسا يومها على نقيه
بنفسه ورفع من شعبيته من خلال مواقفه
المحافظه جدا على صعيد التربيه او الهجره
الحزب الجمهوري بشكل عام طبعا سيدعم ترامب
لان ديسانس لم يكن سوى استمرار لسياسه
ونهج ترامب في الحكم وحتى شخصيه ترامب
لكنه ليس ترامب يقول هنا الخبراء الذين
اوضحوا بان ديسانتيس يراهن على فوزه من
خلال فرضيه عدم خوض ترامب للانتخابات سواء
بسبب اوضاع قانونيه او اوضاع صحيه ليبقى
ترامب الاكثر تفضيلا لدى الجمهوريين لسبب
قاعدته الشعبيه الكبيره والاحصاءات التي
تشير الى انه يتمتع بدعم حوالي اربعين
بالمئه من الاصوات بين 34 الى 40% من
الاصوات الانتخابيه للجمهوريين في معسكره
الذين سيصوتون له في الانتخابات التمهيديه
تحت اي ظرف وهنا مشاهدينا لابد من الاشاره
الى انه في الانتخابات التمهيديه لا يحتاج
المرشحون الى اغلبيه بل يحتاجون فقط الى
الفوز بفارق صوت واحد
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي
مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه يعني
اليوم هناك حديث كسر بالاونه الاخيره عن
اجندتين ممكن ان يلعب عليهما ديسانتسون
الثقافيه والاشندا العمريه او او عمره
الذي فيه فارق كبير بينه وبين المرشح
الثاني الى اي مدى ممكن ان تلعب دور
بالانتخابات المقبله
مساء الخير الليالي اعتقد بانه مبكر ان
نحكم على نجاح
ديسنتوس لانه كما ذكرتي الرئيس ترامب لا
يزال يتربى على راس الهرم بالنسبه
للتفضيليه من قبل الحزب الجمهوري واليوم
رسميا هو سيعلن الترشح وبالتالي بعد
الترشح الرسمي سيكون له حملات ومهرجانات
انتخابيه في كافه الولايات لمحاوله اقناع
الناخب الجمهوري واحيانا المستقل بانه
الجدير بقياده وزعامه الحزب الجمهوري
لمواجهه الرئيس ترامب الرئيس بايدن في
الانتخابات القادمه لكن ما ذكرتيهما هنا
بان هناك بالفعل اجنده خصوصا في ولايه
فلوريدا استطاع ان يطبقها مثلا هو اصدر
قرارات تنفيذيه يحرم الاجهاض يمنعه
قانونيا بعد سته اسابيع وهو يعتبر ربما
فتره
متطرفه نوعا ما بالنسبه لي حتى الجمهوريين
ايضا اصدر قرارات بالمنع الانف الحكوميه
وقرارات ليست في صالح المثليين والى اخره
اذا هو بالفعل يتحدث عن
القيم الجمهوريه لكن ضمن ربما الطرف
المتشدد جدا في داخل الحزب الجمهوري سنرى
اذا كانت هذه هي هموم الجمهوريين وايضا
بالنسبه للعمر يعني بالنهايه بايدن هو
بالسبعينات وبالتالي هو يطرح نفسه كرئيس
بالاربعينات وهو رئيس صغير ولدي يتمتع
بصحه جيده لكن هل يتمتع بالكاريزما التي
يتمتع بها الرئيس ترامب وهل يستطيع ان
يتخطى هذه النسبه 57% حتى الان الى 20%
مقابلها طبعا المشوار طويل جدا بين الان
وبين الترشح الرسمي للحزب في صيف العام
القادم
ناديه ايضا يعني بحسب متابعتك هناك داخل
الحزب هل هناك اي انقسامات حول هذا
الموضوع خصوصا ان هناك يعني بالفتره
الماضيه العديد من
الاراء حول اداء ترامب او جنوح ترامب او
غيره هل ممكن ان يستفيد منها ديسنتس
يمكن الى حد ما لكن الرئيس ترامب لا يزال
يحتفظ بقاعده ربما اظهرت الولاء له منذ ان
ترشها في انتخابات عام 2016 هذه القاعده
لم تغير اياها بالرئيس ترامب لا بظل كل
هذه الملاحقات القانونيه او حتى الاتهامات
بالنسبه لعلاقته مع النساء وغيرها هذه
القاعده ستبقى وفيه للرئيس ترامب لكنها
غير كافيه للفوز بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
ربما كافيه لحصوله على ترشح الحزب
الجمهوري في الانتخابات الاوليه وبالتالي
هناك بعض الانقسامات لكن ايضا ليس بينه
وبين ديسنتوس رغم ان ترامب يعتبره بالفعل
الخصم الجدي الاكثر لانه باقي المرشحين
كما ذكرتني
وغيرهم لا يزالون يحصلون على اقل من 5%
وبالتالي ربما هذه نسبه ضئيله جدا حتى
بالنسبه للرئيس ترامب لان يعبرها اذا
اردتي ويعتبرهم منافسين حقيقيين لكن هناك
ايضا بعض الجمهورين
التقليديين مثل السنه الثوم مثلا اظهر
دعمه الى تيمسكوت وهو سيكون اول مرشح
جمهوري من اصول افريقيه عن ولايه سافكر
والعنايه يتنافس ايضا كانت حاكمه
سطحيه نوعا ما لانه الرئيس لا يزال والاله
الحزبيه في الحزب الجمهوري لا تزال تدعم
الرئيس ترامب وبقوه ناديه قبل ان اختم
سانتقل الى موضوع اخر وهو ايضا بصلب يعني
الخلاف بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
موضوع الموازنه العامه كان هناك اجتماع
بين مجلس النواب والرئيس على موضوع يعني
الاتفاق الاليه التي يمكن ان يخرج فيها
هذا الاتفاق او ماذا يتضمن الاتفاق حتى
هذه اللحظه بحسب المعطيات
يعني كل ساعه هناك معطيات جديده يعني قبل
حوالي ساعه ونصف من الان كنا نتحدث عن
الوصول الى نقطه مسدوده وبان كيف المقاس
رئيس المجلس يتهم البيت الابيض والجناح
اليساري التقدمي بانهم مدمنين على الانفاق
وبالتالي لا يريدون ان يقدموا اي مساومه
لكن خلال ساعه من الان علمنا بانه بالفعل
هناك مفاوضين عن رئيس مجلس النواب سيتجهون
الى البيت الابيض عصر هذا اليوم وربما
سيكون هناك حلحله في الموضوع هذا سيؤثر
بشكل كبير على التوقعات باسعار البورصه
والمال وهول سويت والاقتصاد العالمي
باجمله رغم ان هناك حديث بالفعل بانه لا
يمكن للولايات المتحده ان تتخلف عن دفع
ديونها سواء كان تاكيدات من الجمهورين او
حتى من البيت الابيض لكن الوصول الى نقاط
التي يمكن ان تعتبرها الطرفين ربما تنازل
هي الصعوبه في هذا وخصوصا واننا نتحدث عن
حزب جمهوري فيه الكثير من التشد التطرف من
قبل الجناح اليميني الذي لا يريد ان يقدم
اي تنازل للديمقراطين وهذا يفرق عن
السنوات الماضيه سواء كانت العهد كل
الرؤساء الذين انتموا الى الحزب
الديمقراطي وكل رؤساء المجلس الذي كان
يعارضون سياسه البيت الابيض لكن المشكله
الان كما راينا كيف المقاس نفسه اخذ 11
يوما يتم انتخابه في كرئيس المجلس بمعارضه
ما يسمى بالجمهوريين اليمنيين او
المتطرفين لذا اعتقد بانه بالنهايه قد
نتوصل الى حل لانه لا احد ان يصدق بان
الدوله العظمى بالعالم اقتصاديا وعسكريا
يمكن ان تتخلف عن ديونها لكن حتى نصل الى
الاول من يونيو هناك الكثير من المهارات
السياسيه وربما التنازلات التي على البيت
الابيض ايضا ان يقدمها شكرا لكن ناديه
البلبيسي مديره مكتب العربيه حدثنا من
واشنطن
التاسعه مستمره بعد قليل
بعدما حذر من خطورته بوقت سابق ايلون ماسك
يدعوا لاشعال المنافسه على تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كان في البدايه من مؤسسي
شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي ثم تحول بشكل
مفاجئ الى عدو لها يدعو لايقاف تطوير هذه
التقنيه والان يدعو الى التنافس في هذا
القطاع نتحدث هنا طبعا عن ايلون ماسك الذي
شدد على ضروره وحاجه انشاء شركه ذكاء
الصناعي لمنافسه جوجل ومايكروسوفت يمكن ان
تشمل اجزاء مختلفه من امبراطوريه شركته
بما في ذلك موقع تويتر هذا هو ادنى ماسك
بهذه التعليقات خلال قمه مجلس الرؤساء
التنفيذيين لصحيفه وولد الامريكيه في لندن
واقترح ماسك بحسب الصحيفه ان يكون تويتر
جزءا من جهوده لانشاء شركه ذكاء الصناعي
وقال ان تويتر وتسلا يمكن ان يكون شريكين
مع شركه ذكاء اصطناعي بحسب الصحيفه التي
اشارت الى ان ماسك انشا شركه ذكاء الصناعي
تسمى اكس اي اي وقلم ماسك اعتقد انه يجب
ان يكون هناك حصان ثالث مهم في هذا السباق
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من عمان رائد سمور
خبير امن وتكنولوجيا المعلومات استاذ رائد
يعني كل حمله المخاطر التي قادها
بالفتره الماضيه ماسك اتضح بانها ليست الا
حمله تاخير ليعود هو الى السوق ويكون رائد
هذا المجال اليوم ما الذي يريده من هذا
التطور التكنولوجي وكيف سيقوده وسيغير بكل
المشهد التكنولوجي بالفتره المقبله الذكاء
الاصطناعي طبعا
مساء الخير حقيقه بالبدايه يعني لابد من
التنويه الجزئيه معينه حتى ان نكون منصفين
بحق ايلون ماسك نعم هو كان عدو مش بالمعنى
العداوه
المطلقه قال قال اذا ترك الذكاء الاصطناعي
بدون تشريع يضبطه هو خطير جدا وكان يعني
واضح كلامه بشكل كبير فعمليا هو دعا الى
عمليات تشريع خاصه لضبط هذا الذكاء
الاصطناعي وتطور هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي
بشكل كبير هذا كان لابد من الاشاره له من
باب المصداقيه فقط اما بخصوص تصريحاته بما
يختص الحصان الثالث هو الحقيقه هو هون
اراد من خلال
اهمال شركه متى على انها موجوده في سوق
الذكاء الاصطناعي ومتواجدي في سوق الذكاء
الاصطناعي وبقوه ايضا انا اعتقد هذا كانت
رساله الى شركه متى من تحت البلاط بالمعنى
الدارج عنا فعمليا انه
شركه ميتا تفكر الان باصدار نموذج جديد
يحاكي تويتر
بمحطه مركزيه خاصه
ان تكون بالمقابل نعم هو اراد ان تكون
بالمقابل اللي هي
لتشمل تويتر وتشمل الذكاء الاصطناعي في ان
واحد ففي عمليا انا اعتقد هي وجه من وجوه
هي وجه من اوجه الصراع على يعني على رياده
السوق ولكن تحول شركه
اوبن اي اي الى شركه ربحيه كانت يعني نقطه
التحول بهذا المجال اليوم يعني من المعروف
على على ماسك بانه يريد ان يكون الرائد
باي مجال يدخل اليه وبالتالي عندما يقول
حصان ثالث هل سيكون الحصان الاول عمليا
بالفتره المقبله
اذا كان الحصان الاول على مستوى منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي ولننظر ماذا جرى في
منصه تويتر من خلال قيادته هل من الممكن
ان يكون هو يعني الحصان الاول او المرتبه
الاولى في في موضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي انا
لا اعتقد ذلك على الاطلاق هذا الرجل يقسم
وقته ثلاث اجزاء يوميا جزء لتويتر وجزء
لسبيس اكس وجزء لتسلا فعمليا يعني
الموضوع موضوع اكبر من هذه المساله
الموضوع يحتاج الى تخطيط ويحتاج الى الى
مؤسسات كبرى ولا يحتاج الى تفكير شخص رجل
واحد فقط ويتخذ القرار بشكل يعني غير
مدروس انا لا اعتقد انه سوف يكون لا ثالث
ولا رابع في في هذا السباق على الاطلاق ان
لم يخرج حتى يعني بطريقه اداءه وبطريقه
ادارته اللي كانت سابقا موجوده على تويتر
انا اعتقد حتى تويتر يعني في مهب الريح
الان و مستقر فكيف سيكون يعني من الاوائل
في في موضوع الاي اي انا اعتقد ذلك انه
يعني بعيد نوعا ما وبعيد المنال
بما يختص السيده الون ماسك يعني لا اعتقد
لا اعتقد انه سوف يكون في يوم من الايام
منافسا على المراتب الاولى قد يكون موجود
في المعادله نعم لانه الذكاء الاصطناعي
يستخدم يعني موجود لننصف ايضا ماسك يعني
هو من اول من استثمر بهذا الموضوع ومن اول
من دخل بهذه يعني الماركت قبل اي احد اخر
وبالتالي وليس متاخرا ولكن طبعا هناك
حسابات رجل الاعمال وايضا كل حسابات السوق
وغيره شكرا لك استاذ رائد سمور خبير امن
وتكنولوجيا المعلومات حدثتنا من عمان
[موسيقى]
نبه اعلى مسؤول طبي في الولايات المتحده
من ان الشبكات الاجتماعيه قد تتسبب باثار
ضاره جدا على الصحه النفسيه للاطفال
والمراهقين داعيا عمالقه التكنولوجيا في
تقريره الى التحرك حيال هذه المخاطر
ادمان رقمي يصيب الشباب وتحذيرات من
استخدامه طويلا حدا اللاوعي مدير هيئه
الصحه العامه في الولايات المتحده فيفيك
مورثي ناشد في تقرير طبي كل المعنيين
بالصحه النفسيه للمراهقين مؤكدا ان هناك
حاجه ماسه لوضع قيود تكنولوجيه وحتى
عائليه على استخدامها واستنادا لمركز بيول
للابحاث فان نحو 95% ما بين 13 و17 عاما
يشاهدون يوتيوب وسبعه وستون في المئه
يدمنون تيك توك اما انستجرام فبالنسبه 62%
ويليه سناب شات بواقع
59%
الطبيب اكد وجود صله بين استعمالها وظهور
اعراض الاكتئاب لاسيما على المراهقات
اللاواتي يتعرضن للتنمر اكثر من الشباب
عدا عن ان الفئه العمريه هذه بشكل عام قد
تصادفها محتويات خطيره داعيا الى توصيات
تشبه ما اقرتهم مونتانا اول ولايه امريكيه
تحضر تيك توك لمن لم يتجاوز 18 عاما اما
جوجل فقد وضعت توصيه خمسا لمساعده الابناء
على ان يكونوا مستكشفين امنين لعالم
الانترنت شارك بعنايه وانتبه من التزييف
واحمي اسرارك وانشر الايجابيه وتحدث عما
يريبك اساسيات اذا تعلمه الطفل مبكرا
تحميه من اي اعتلالات نفسيه قد تصيبه من
عدوى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اظهرت صور ملتقطه لزعيم كوريا الشماليه
وهو منحنى امام قبر مسؤول عسكري في خطوه
مفاجئه وتعتبر خروجا كبيرا عن تقاليده
ونشرت الصوره او نشرت الصوره في الجريده
الرسميه حيث اظهرت كم الكثير اظهر فيها كم
الكثير من التواضع امام قبر القائد
العسكري الراحل هيون تشول هاي الذي رسخ
حياته باكملها للعمل كحارس شخصي مخلص
لعائله كم واظهر ولائه المطلق له
وصل ملك بريطانيا تشارلز الثالث وزوجته
كاملا الى ايرلندا الشماليه في زيارات هي
الاولى منذ تتويجهما وتعتبر هذه اول زياره
رسميه لهما خارج بريطانيا منذ التتويج
والسهل لها في حديقه التتويج
دهمت السلطات الالمانيه 15 عقارا في انحاء
البلاد وصادرت اصولا في اطار تحقيق يتعلق
بتمويل مظاهرات نظمتها جماعه معنيه
بالمناخ بحسب الادعاء العامل الالماني
الذي اوضح انه يحقق مع سبعه اشخاص
للاشتباه في تشكيلهم او دعمهم منظمه
اجراميه ذلك بعدما اغلق اعضاء الجماعه
الطرق في البلاد للضغط على الحكومه لاتخاذ
اجراءات صارمه تتعلق بتغيير المناخ
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
كازوني
لاول مره البحريه الروسيه تتعرض لهجوم
اوكرانيا في البوسفور ومنفذوه هجوم بيل
جورد يظهرون للعالم
على واقع اصوات اشتباكات متقطعه في
الخرطوم واشنطن تعلن سعيها لايجاد اليه
لمراقبه الهدنه
بارز في حزب عمران يستقيل من منصبه
والحكومه الباكستانيه تبحث خطه لحظر الحزب
الى قرب التوصل لحل ازمه الدين مع بايدن
ويؤكد وجود خلافات بشان الانفاق
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره والان الى 360 مع الزميله راويه
راويه مساء الخير وماذا لديك اهلا بك ليال
سنتحدث عن الهجوم الاوكراني بالمسيارات
المائيه في منطقه البوسفور وايضا عن
سيناريوهات ازمه سقف الديون في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تفضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات